non
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission un grand reportage
les vapes auteurs peuvent souffler les
parlementaires européens se sont
prononcés pour que la cigarette
électronique ne soit pas considérée
comme un médicament la e-cigarette
pourra donc continuer à être vendus dans
les boutiques spécialisées ou chez les
buralistes
c'est ce qu'ont décidé les eurodéputés
bon sens aux victoires des lobbys retour
sur les coulisses de cette semaine
décisive au parlement européen semaine
décisive pour la cigarette électronique
mais avant un tout autre sujet posons
nous une question assistons à une vague
de fond extrémistes en europe
peur de l'immigration crise économique
crise identitaire jamais le terrain à
n'aura été aussi propice à l'idéologie
ultra nationaliste et anti européenne
alors une question l'europe virtel
populiste
jamais le terrain n'a été aussi
favorable au parti populiste
ultranationaliste anti immigration et
anti européens en grande bretagne ce
rejet de l'europe est incarnée par
l'ukip le parti pour l'indépendance du
royaume uni son leader a proposé aux
conservateurs de voter pour ses
candidats aux européennes
objectif obliger david cameron a
organisé un référendum sur la sortie de
l'europe du royaume uni la poussée de
l'extrême droite en autriche aussi
l'autriche où le chômage est pourtant au
plus bas son leader digne héritier de
jorg haider jure que l'amour du prochain
son slogan de campagne passe par la
préférence autrichienne et la fin du
centralisme bruxellois en grèce ça va
encore plus loin
look doré de nikos nique à laugnac
hausse prône une radicalité absolue avec
une face sombre ouvertement raciste
prête à éliminer physiquement les
immigrés en france
la victoire du candidat front national
laurent lopez lors d'une cantonale
partielle à brignoles annonce une
poussée de son parti aux municipales de
2014 aux européennes aussi le parti de
marine le pen est crédité dans les
sondages de 24% des intentions de vote
devant l'ump le ps front national
premier parti france alors les élections
européennes verront-elles l'explosion
des eurosceptiques
voilà l'europe virtel populiste
alors nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bruno gollnisch bonjour bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés français front national
alors question tout ça fait ce que vous
vous sentez une vague de fond des partis
extrémistes en europe
je me permettrai de vous reprendre et
aussi un petit peu votre présentation je
crois que nous sommes extremis en rien
nous agissons dans le cadre d'un strict
de la légalité nous avons n'avons jamais
attaqué physiquement nos adversaires
bien que souvent nos réunions les tétées
nous avons subi des lois électorales
parfaitement injuste et nous ne sommes
donc pas extrémiste dans la forme je
vois pas que nous soyons dans le fond
mais ce qui clarifie bout classifiés
dans la droite extrémiste extrême droite
vous acceptez cette dénomination ça
aurait pu être acceptable pour certains
d'entre eux si c'est un positionnement
politique dans la mesure où l'ump se
revendique maintenant de la droite ce
qui n'était pas le cas autrefois
alors évidemment comme nous sommes plus
patriote plus l'autre at il encore une
fois c'est un positionnement de de
géographie politique mais non ce serait
une droite libérale sous les pas des
impôts extrême droite par rapport aux
questions de société voulait un
référendum sur sur sur les ivg extrême
droite et rapport à la vérité à la
droite souverainiste vous voulez sortir
de l'euro donc c'est ce sont des faits
doit non mais il n'y a pas et il n'y a
rien d'extrémiste de dande dans tout
cela
en ce qui concerne l'euro d'ailleurs
l'euro se dégradent hélas tout seul nous
sommes des gens responsables ce que nous
prévoyons c'est précisément les
solutions de rechange parce que
gouverner c'est prévoir dit la sagesse
populaire
il y a d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui rejoignent le front national
je crois que le véritable clivage n'est
plus tellement entre droite et gauche
il est entre eux d'une certaine façon
des patriots qui sont attachés à la
défense de leur identité nationale d'une
part et les mondialistes ceux qui
estiment que la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises et des
capitaux a réalisé une espèce de
gigantesque brassage qui apportera le
bonheur et la prospérité et nous nous
considérons et nous ne sommes pas les
seuls c'est vrai que cela porte la
prospérité pour quelques-uns une toute
petite minorité mais que ça contribue à
l'appauvrissement du plus grand nom mais
offrent aux fondations la coque quel
lien vous avez avec un parti comme on
vient de le voir le clip en grande
bretagne où un parti comme l'aube dorée
en grèce on a fait un vrai rapport nous
n'avons aucun lien avec l'eau borée
d'ailleurs ils ne soient pas représentés
au parlement européen et je ne sais pas
lire ce qu'il en est de cette affaire
criminelle du tout je constate
d'ailleurs que la présomption
d'innocence dont on nous rebat les
oreilles ne joue pas je si un parti
d'extrême gauche voyait tous ces députés
arrêté soudainement sans levée
d'immunité parlementaire sans autre
procédure
je pense que ici au parlement européen
on entendrait beaucoup de protestations
sur tous les bancs mais écoutez invité
un jour les gens de l'aube dorée ils
sont assez grands pour sûr pour vous
répondre
en revanche en revanche ce qui est exact
c'est que le front national et jean
marie le pen ont été leaders ont été
pionniers dans la défense d' identité
menacée et 7
ce sentiment que les identités sont
menacés que le brassage des personnes à
une échelle gigantesque qui est voulu
par certains dirigeants apportent des
problèmes de société que l'ouverture des
marchés à des pays qui font travailler
les ouvriers dans des conditions
d'esclavagé ruine nos économies que la
monnaie unique n'est pas adapté à des
économies qui sont extrêmement
différentes d'un pays à l'autre
ce sentiment de frustration contre ce
qu'on peut appeler les trahisons des
promesses européennes
eh bien il se répand en europe et nous
sommes en contact bien sûr avec beaucoup
de nos crus
je britannique justement il ya un débat
la semaine dernière au parlement
européen sur la montée des extrêmes je
vous propose d'écouter l'une des
intervenantes sylvie guillaume qui est
heureux député kaki qui tente
d'expliquer pourquoi il y aurait cette
montée des extrêmes en europe écoutez
vous réagissez juste après
ces partis extrémistes de droite se
nourrissent de l'angoissé provoquée par
la crise et par le désarroi économique
par la violence d'une mondialisation non
maîtrisée qui fait perdre les repères
qui s'appuie sur une rhétorique qui fait
de l'autre le responsable de tous les
maux alors pour contrer cette
progression dont l'idéologie porte les
germes d'une violence inacceptable il
faut d'abord agir en termes économiques
voilà c'était sylvie c'était sylvie
guillaume c c'est la ritournelle
habituelle c'est pas vous vous
nourrissez des peurs et c'est à vous
nourrissez de la crise écrit ses
collègues de la crise économique mais
nous serions extrêmement heureux s'il
n'y avait pas de crise économique
ce n'est pas nous qui lavons provoqué la
crise économique la crise économique
elle est provoquée par le déclin
industriel du monde occidental par une
ouverture inconsidérée des frontières
qui met par exemple ouvriers français en
concurrence directe avec l'ouvrier
chinois qui est payé 20 fois moins
qui n'a pas de protection sociale qui
n'a pas de pension de retraite et qui
étend dans un pays communiste n'a pas le
droit de faire grève si madame guillaume
veut résoudre ces problèmes
eh bien il faut qu'elle rétablisse une
protection raisonnable à nos frontières
justement sur le plan économique il est
tout à fait faux d'ailleurs que nous
faisons des immigrés les boucs
émissaires il y a un problème
d'immigration massive un contrôle et
parfois non intégrés dans nos pays
mais les responsables de cette situation
ce ne sont pas les immigrés eux-mêmes ce
sont les responsables politiques et
économiques aux alentours de man en de
mouvaux de programmes européens c'est
quoi vous n'êtes pas pour une europe
fédérale d'être pour une ordination vous
êtes pour la sortie de l'euro nous le
l'euro est en train de se désagréger et
nous voyons bien d'ailleurs ce qu'il en
est quand un pays n'a plus la maîtrise
de sa monnaie nationale ce qui tentera
aussi assez curieusement d'arriver aux
états unis
par conséquent nous prévoyons la sortie
de tout cela ce que nous voudrions c'est
le respect de du patrimoine politique et
spirituelle de l'europe l'europe c'est
l'espace qui dans l'histoire de
l'humanité a inventé la liberté des
nations
ça nous est aujourd'hui évident mais ça
ne l'a pas toujours été
il ya des civilisations qui ne
connaissent pas cela qui ne connaissent
que la domination de 2 par exemple de
l'empereur de chine en extrême orient ou
que sais-je où le mythe du califat dans
notre civilisation
nous nous avons légalité des nations
petites ou grandes leur liberté leur
souveraineté
nous voudrions conserver cela mais ne
nous sommes pas opposés
nous ne sommes évidemment pas opposés à
toute coopération européenne qu'il y ait
des coopérations scientifiques qu'il y a
des copains des échanges d'étudiants
comme erasmus qu'il y ait par exemple le
lancement de satellites galileo pour que
nous ayons un satellite indépendant des
états unis d'amérique mais au moins que
ce soient des promeneurs à noter ces
précisions sur les chiffres et quand il
flashe sur lesquels les citoyens
puissent mettre un bilan coût avantage
merci monsieur gollnisch d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
maintenant place aux reportages le
parlement européen a donné son feu vert
à une nouvelle législation pour rendre
moins attractifs les produits du tabac
mais a refusé que les cigarettes
électroniques soient vendus
exclusivement qu'en pharmacie la
cigarette électronique ne sera pas
considéré comme comme un médicament et
pourra l'acheter un peu partout dans les
boutiques spécialisées ou chez le
buraliste
alors retour sur une semaine cruciale de
la cigarette électronique au parlement
européen c'est un reportage signé yoan
là
il ne visitent son entreprise compte
tenu de laborantin blouse blanche et
charlotte dans une vie antérieure
charlie 40 ans était un ingénieur
d'affaires aujourd'hui le voici
directeur commercial de ce laboratoire
qui fait sa fierté la mm caraîbes et si
vous avez un petit peu le coeur du
procédé
c'est à dire le conditionnement façon
c'est là où on élabore vraiment des
flacons sur mesure pour nos clients dans
ces petits flacons le carburant des
cigarettes électroniques le illiquides
459 fioles aux arômes made in france
produites chaque mois dans l'entreprise
n'ouvrez assemblons nous mêmes les
arômes naturels de manière à ce qu'il
soit suffisamment subtil avec une
approche la plus cohérente possible pour
le bape otages c'est vraiment comme de
la cuisine on est passé d'une personne
vincent uniquement qu'il m'en faisais
ces essais dans son laboratoire a
aujourd'hui 50 personnes pour le
fondateur aux fourneaux quelques mètres
plus loin la croissance est exceptionnel
15 % par mois en un an
l'entreprise de cet ancien fumeur
converti à la cigarette électronique
s'est imposé comme le deuxième fabricant
français de illiquides
je suis
d'améliorations à apporter sur un
produit qui pouvait à l'époque
essentiellement de chine où il y avait
une envie de la fiscalité en la matière
j'ai envie de savoir exactement qu'est
ce que je n'allais dernière
investissement cette machine justement
destinés à contrôler leurs produits pour
suivre la demande
vincent et charlie vont surtout devoir
doubler leurs capacités de production
mais pour l'instant pas question de s'en
réjouir
ces lignes la coûte très cher et nos
investissements sont effectivement en
attente d'une réponse de la part du
parlement européen car depuis quelques
semaines la cigarette électronique est
bel et bien dans le collimateur de
l'europe
lundi 7 octobre à strasbourg
un drôle de mouvements de protestation
sur le parvis du parlement européen
300 utilisateurs venus crier leur colère
en cause
l'examen le lendemain d'une directive
sur le tabac dont l'une des mesures
phares pourrait bien signer la fin de la
libre distribution de cigarettes
électroniques sa classification en
médicaments
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est que la
cigarette électronique puisse faire
concurrence au tabac si demain on la
renvoie en pharmacie cette concurrence
disparaîtra il sera plus facile
d'acheter du tabac que d'acheter une
cigarette électronique est donc les gens
se tourneront vers le plus facile
beaucoup de français quelques belges
allemands ou néerlandais et un seul
slogan dans toutes les langues
la vente en pharmacie sera le pire des
signaux à envoyer aux fumeurs
les accros à la nicotine ça voudra
seulement dire retournez à la cigarette
et pour les nouveaux consommateurs ça
sera toujours la même rengaine 25 à 30 %
des européens vont continuer à fumer
commencé à fumer et continue d'en mourir
ce jour-là charlie est aussi du voyage
venus parler d'emploi avec une
eurodéputée britannique qui refuse ce
statut de médicament
on est maintenant de quel côté penchera
le parlement les vapes auteurs vont
devoir composer avec un puissant
adversaire
selon la presse anglo saxonne le plus
gros acteur du tabac philip morris
aurait à lui seul dépensé plus de cent
millions d'euros pour influencer les
parlementaires sur cette directive
contacté par téléphone le groupe n'a pas
souhaité nous rencontrer mais confirme
par un communiqué s'être engagé en
faveur d'un durcissement de la
législation sur la cigarette
électronique
au vu des développements technologiques
et de leur potentiel en termes de santé
publique
il est impératif que les autorités
établissent un cadre réglementaire
rigoureux qui régissent l'ensemble de
ses nouveaux produits et ce y compris
pour les cigarettes électroniques
farouche adversaire de ce lobby
l'eurodéputé écologiste michèle rivasi
témoigne de ses nombreuses tentatives d'
approche au fil des semaines à ce qu'on
a reçu c'était dans un paquet comme ceci
avec de l'info donc c'est pas il n'y a
pas marqué philip morris ou british
american tobacco aksas et le lobby
mafieux du tabac pas question de
transiger en matière de santé publique
pourtant l'euro député votera ce statut
de médicament
trop d'incertitudes sur les effets de la
cigarette électronique à long terme
est ce que le fait de commencer par la
cigarette électronique pour des jeunes
ça va pas les inciter à après puisqu'ils
ont toujours l'habitude de tout dire
quelque chose dans la mal à passer à la
cigarette
voilà pourtant quelques minutes plus
tard et malgré l'avis négatif de la
députée en charge de la directive
le vote sera bel et bien une surprise
la cigarette électronique ne sera pas un
médicament et 7 retours en banlieue
bordelaise
si la victoire de la veille fait les
gros titres charlie se prépare déjà pour
d'autres batailles la guerre des
distributeurs et des buralistes et
surtout l'arrivée imminente des géants
du tabac sur le marché
c'est rémy qui peuvent nous appeler nous
pour l'instant on laissera la passion
devant la passion de travail créé une
entreprise c'est pas pour l'abandonner
quelques jours après quoi si plus
personne ne semble la remettre en cause
la bataille pour la cigarette
électronique vient d'entrer dans une
nouvelle phase
certains acteurs pourraient en
bénéficier d'autres
s'évaporer
alors un reportage signé yoan heure-là
deux invités nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau je suis bien entouré bonjour
mesdames françoise grosse tête vous êtes
députée européenne ppe en france vous
êtes ump membres de la commission de
l'environnement et santé publique du
parlement européen vous vous avez été
voté contre le fait que la cigarette
électronique soit considéré comme un
médicament vous avez été entendu vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi vos côtés
michèle rivasi bonjour bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputée europe ecologie les verts
partisane d'un encadrement plus strict
vous avez voté pour que la cigarette
électronique que soient vendus en
pharmacie vous n'avez pas été entendu on
vous a vu dans le reportage vous avez
reçu un gros colis ça venait de
l'industrie du tabac s'il y avait quoi
dedans il y avait énormément de tabac en
vrac avec des contenants qui disait vous
voyez sont recyclables
c'est dire que maintenant l'industrie du
tabac voyez va vise à l'environnement
plus des cigarettes électroniques et
grosso modo on considère que l'industrie
du tabac a investi à peu près 7000 euros
alors tout confondu avec leurs
consultants par député européen donc
vous voyez le chiffre annoncé 100
millions d'euros sur l'ensemble ils ont
fait un lobby incroyable lorsque vous
avez reçu une invitation à dîner
j'ai reçu le tabac en vrac et j'ai reçu
une invitation à dîner pour la semaine
prochaine
invitations envoyées bien évidemment
avant le vote partie par l'industrie du
tabac dans un restaurant très réputé de
strasbourg
alors une question toute simple peut le
parlement européen a exclu avant de l'y
cigarettes en pharmacie est ce que c'est
une bonne chose
c'est une mauvaise chose écoutez sur la
cigarette électronique considéré comme
un médicament moi je ne pouvais pas
adhéré à cette théorie là estime d'abord
que la cigarette électronique
aujourd'hui est utilisé par un certain
nombre de fumeurs qui se disent que
c'est un moyen pour eux peut-être de
quitter un jour la cigarette la
cigarette traditionnelle mais si on vend
cette cigarette électronique dans une
pharmacie d'abord c'est un frein c'est
un frein justement pour aller acheter
cette cigarette électronique que l'on
trouve aujourd'hui dans des boutiques
chez des buralistes etc
d'autre part considéré la cigarette
électronique d'aujourd'hui fait comme
elle est faite aujourd'hui ce délai il
ya 400 cigarettes électroniques
différentes et certaines qui peuvent
être extrêmement dangereuses parce que
pas contrôlés dans leur fabrication
considérer qu'elle allait de pouvoir
devenir un médicament cela entraînait
une vraie dépréciation de ce qui est de
la définition du médicament lui-même
vendu en officine
vous n'êtes pas d'accord non je suis pas
du tout d'accord parce que dans votre
reportage et vous même madame grosses
têtes vous dites ça doit être
exclusivement vendus en pharmacie
c'était pas vrai c'est le problème des
états membres chaque état membre peut
décider vente en pharmacie et à
l'extérieur
donc moi j'étais favorable à ce que ça
soit vendu dans des différents commerces
même spécialisés pour l'information de
consommateurs moi ce qui m'inquiète et
pourquoi je voulais une autorisation de
mise sur le marché
allégée et je voulais pas que on tape
financièrement sur les cigarettes
électroniques mais on ne sait rien sur
les cigarettes électroniques ou de ddd
rihanna 400 y en a énormément qui
viennent d'asie qui viennent d'ailleurs
là vous avez quelqu'un qui fabrique des
cocktails je suis pas suivre mais
contient plus de cent neuf cocktails à
base de sex on the beach
il ya un des trucs incroyables il n'y a
aucun contrôle
on s'aperçoit qu'il peut y avoir de rôle
et moins dangereuse que les cigarettes
normales et ya pas de monoxyde de
carbone responsables des infarctus il
n'y a pas de goudron responsables de
cancer de poumon la nicotine et ont salé
l'addition mal dit et nous est ce que je
voulais c'est un contrôle pour savoir
quels sont les effets à moyen et à long
terme et faire en sorte à ce que quand
vous dis parce que y'a des cigarettes
électeurs à la nicotine
les patchs que l'on met pour les
justement les gens qui veulent arrêter
ils ont leurs autorisations de mise sur
marché pourquoi on n'aurait pas fait un
truc voyez plus light en disant on va
contrôler on va voir les effets
sanitaires
même si je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
moins toxique que la sig
seulement il faut un contrôle qu'elle
contrôle on va avoir
vous allez avoir toussé toute cette
nicotine et en os le peu de contrôle on
voit que c'est même pas la quantité qui
a affiché il faut quand même les
contrôler ces gens-là bon sens en
réalité on la directive que nous avons
votée elle prévoit l'encadrement de la
cigarette électronique encadrement à
travers sa production sa fabrication sa
production et la distribution interdite
aux mineurs et interdiction de faire de
la publicité mais ça ça c'est contre
sara ziff co tiens c'est un pas en avant
alors si il va y avoir des contrôles
parce que dans notre notre encadrement
législatif
il va y avoir effectivement la nécessité
de ne pas dépasser un certain
pourcentage de nigro nicotine ceci étant
dit ça ne peut pas être considéré comme
un médicament et surtout pas comparer
aux patchs à la nicotine
les patchs à la nicotine on le prend
quand véritablement on veut arrêter de
fumer
tandis qu'actuellement les vapoteurs ce
sont des gens qui fument d'habitude qui
sont très contents une recharge et une
recharge de cigarettes électroniques ça
coûte 6 euros
c'est l'équivalent de 7 paquets de
cigarettes est ce que c'est pas là
l'explication du succès c'est à dire à
des fumeurs kiseki feront des économies
et qui ont un espoir de vie meilleure
alors mais si vous voulez ça moi je
trouve qu'il ya deux publics ya
effectivement le public des gens qui
veulent arrêter de fumer
et ça ça demande est quand même un
contrôle parce que s'il ya 40 60 mg de
nicotine 30 ou 2 mg c'est quand même pas
la même chose
donc il fallait l'encadrement mais aussi
vous moi ce qui m'inquiète
si vous avez vu le succès de la
cigarette électronique et surtout en
france d'ailleurs
et il s'adresse aux jeunes pourquoi il
ya plus de cent quatre cocktails et
c'est pas n'importe quoi
vous avez à la framboise interroge vous
attend dans le reportage on a
généralement l'habitude de mettre en
avant quelques cadres qui vous
interpellent qui vous interpellent ou
parlementaire alors on a interviewé
directeur commercial de 6 fabrique des
cigarettes électroniques sa filière elle
marche
il vous pose une question sur sa filière
mais on écoute
la france a pris position en se mettant
derrière la position de l'europe
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'elle amène
maintenant que le vote et est établie
pour aider la filière à réellement se
constituer qu'est ce que l'europe peut
faire pour aider la filière a marché à
se constituer la filière de cigarettes
électroniques
mais la directive que nous avons votée
elle n'est pas faite pour soutenir la
filière de la cigarette électronique
elle est faite pour combattre
l'attractivité de la cigarette du tabac
vis-à-vis des jeunes et des femmes car
ce sont deux publics qui sont ciblés par
cette directive tabac alors là on n'est
pas du tout dans la protection de la
cigarette électronique
je tiens à rappeler d'ailleurs à propos
de ce que nous disions auparavant c'est
que ladite d'industrie pharmaceutique
européenne ne souhaite absolument pas et
ne souhaitait pas que cette cigarette
électronique soit défini comme étant un
médicament il n'y a que 1 laboratoire
américain bien connu
très réputé comme étant puissant qui lui
demandait parce que cette cigarette
électronique ils fabriquent déjà soit
considéré comme un médicament alors
attention
ou est ce que j'avais envie de dire à ce
monsieur c'est que on a des intérêts
différents
lui il veut développer sa boîte qu'il
fasse mais nous on est là pour protéger
la santé des consommateurs on veut que
le consommateur soit informé et que le
produit est notamment sa cigarette
assurent la sécurité la sûreté et une
efficacité si ça on n'a pas le même rôle
que il fa s'est produit très bien qui
développe ses produits très bien mais là
où je suis en désaccord avec le
développement de la cigarette
électronique
c'est qu'ils sont entre est de capter
cette jeunesse dont l'objectif de la
directive européenne s'était de diminuer
de 2 % leur consommation
ils sont en train de les capter avec des
produits hyper sexe pour leur dire vous
voyez cigarette électronique c'est le
produit comme ça et après les jeunes eh
ben ils vont se dire eh ben on fait la
cigarette et b demain on fait la
cigarette et je suis persuadé que dans
quelques années le
et le lobby du tabac va racheter toutes
les entreprises parce qu'il ya tellement
de bénéfices à se faire et bien qu'ils
vont vite cher chez le rival si donc la
directive européenne s'était pas que la
cigarette électronique est là aussi
législation contre les produits du tabac
jeux med mesdames je vous rappeler
quelques chiffres
les fumeurs en france ses 14 millions de
fumeurs ce qui représente en france un
chiffre d'affaires de quelque 17
milliards d'euros pour l'industrie du
tabac en france
un fumeur sur deux va mourir ce qui veut
dire que 73 mille morts par an en france
200 morts par par jour des chiffres
effrayants
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
convaincre quelqu'un d'arrêter de fumer
est-ce qu'on fait assez dans la
prévention en europe alors il faut ça
certainement renforcé effectivement
l'information la prévention c'est à dire
tout faire pour que un jeune n'ai pas
envie de toucher à la première cigarette
parce que tous les médecins que nous
avons rencontré les pneumologues les
cancérologues les urologues nous disent
tous les cardiologues aussi nous disent
tous c'est s'éteint c'est un problème la
première cigarette elle est déjà
dangereuse d'emblée donc il faut tout
faire pour éviter que ce jeune est envie
de toucher à cette cigarette tout faire
pour éviter qu'une jeune femme continue
de fumer et de transmettre
malheureusement les les conséquences de
son nom de son addiction au foetus par
exemple tout ceci ça des conséquences
terribles donc il faut beaucoup mieux
informés et quand on parle des images
que l'on a positionné sur le paquet de
cigarettes qui sont des images assez
effrayante à voir on ne dit jamais non
ça sert à rien si il ya eu des sondages
qui ont été faits dans certains pays
entre-temps en grande bretagne qui
montre que cela quand même inquiète
beaucoup les jeunes
donc il y à il ya énormément de
dispositifs à mettre et surtout
supprimer les arômes interdire les arts
où nous avons interdit les arômes pour
le menthol
nous avons été obligés d'accepter un
délai qui me paraît un peu long mais bon
qui est passé de 8 ans mais qui sait si
c'est quoi la suite la suite de ces
directives et maintenant négocier
on est aussi avec les états membres oui
mais les négociations et peut-être que
sur le menthol
états sont pour trois ans donc on va
peut-être réduire mais on a perdu sur
les slims cigarette c'est à dire ces
cigarettes très fille et vous avez
raison
parce que si nérac rakus eurocrates que
l'on n'ait pas pu interdire le menthol
c'est vraiment voyez l'aide ya deux
choses qu'il fallait qu'il faut sur
lequel il faut être très dur c'est
l'attractivité et la diction quand même
il faut que les gens sachent que
l'industrie de la pomme mais plus de
4000 molécules dont des molécules qui
rendent encore plus addictif pour moi
c'est des criminels ces gens là ils ont
un freak dingue
vous avez vu ce qu'ils ont fait en
parlement ils ont voulu acheter
indirectement les députés européens
ils ont fait une pression à l'emploi va
son incroyable dans les états membres et
en plus dans certains états à financer
les campagnes électorales donc ils ont
fait du chantage et ces gens là avec la
quantité de morts je trouve ça
scandaleux ce sera le mot de la fin
merci mesdames d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fin d'europe hebdo
vous retrouver la semaine prochaine
n'aura hamadi pour une nouvelle émission
parlement européen à strasbourg
cette fois d'ici là bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires